it's been reported that elon musk the
founder of tesla and spacex
crossed the threshold to become the
world's second richest person
but we at forbes maintain that musk is
not there yet
and instead is the world's third richest
musk's net worth nearly quadrupled
during the covet 19 pandemic
going from 24.6 billion in mid-march
to 126.8 billion on november 24th
this surge put him past bill gates who
is now fourth richest
and mark zuckerberg at fifth musk trails
french luxury goods tycoon bernard
arnold
and amazon founder jeff bezos so why
exactly do we believe musk is in third
place
well it's a bit technical so bear with
us musk
owns 21 of tesla but he's pledged more
than half his stake as collateral for
personal loans
because of this forbes applies a 25
discount to his shareholding
to account for the loans his net worth
estimate also includes 25 billion
dollars worth of options that was
awarded since may 2020
this was part of a historic 12 tranche
compensation plan
musk became eligible for the fourth
trash in late october
after tesla exceeded the cumulative
ebitda requirement
but tesla has yet to confirm in public
findings that it has certified the
results
and a representative for musk did not
reply to a request for comment from
forbes in time for publication
until the receipt of the fourth trash is
confirmed forbes will only be counting
some
25 million options from the package
towards musk's net worth
you